piratería o terrorismo de estado son
algunas de las reacciones más duras de
los gobiernos europeos y la aerolínea
ryanair ante los sucesos del domingo en
belarús el gobierno de lukashenko las
tilda de infundadas e insiste en que
hubo un aviso de bomba que obligó a
desviar la nave que se dirigía a vilna
la capital de lituania no sabían que
dentro viajaba el periodista opositor
román protosevich afirman algo que
rechazó desde un principio la opositora
sviatlana tija nos calla
y el régimen en volvió a las agencias de
inteligencia o puso aviones de combate y
secuestro todo un avión civil para tomar
a román como rehén desde la vecina
lituania donde se dirigía la aeronave y
lugar de residencia de varios opositores
al régimen de lukashenko se manifestaron
en la misma línea sur eco la vemos para
la extrema na protesta derecho
primero solicitamos la liberación de
roman protosevich en segundo lugar si
esto no se hace
estamos hablando de sanciones muy graves
que también están a disposición de la
unión europea pero hay otras sanciones o
medidas que podrían aplicarse al régimen
incluido el reconocimiento del espacio
aéreo bielorruso como inseguro para la
aviación civil bea but trípode sin
bandas ursula von der leyen presidenta
de la comisión europea confirmó que el
consejo europeo estudiará sanciones este
lunes el comportamiento escandaloso e
ilegal del régimen de belarús debe ser
sancionado el periodista román protege
bis debe ser puesto en libertad de
inmediato el consejo europeo discutirá
mañana las sanciones a tomar las
condenas de lo que se considera que
podría representar una clara violación
de las reglas internacionales del
transporte no se hicieron esperar por el
momento la aerolínea lituana air baltic
anunció que ya no usará el espacio aéreo
bielorruso para sus vuelos comerciales